unsurprised anyone who read Alexis Jays
original report into what had been going
on in rather on that report revealed it
was corrupt it was rotten there was
cover-up young people were not listen to
those who tried to blow the whistle had
their report suppressed files deleted
they were demoted um this was an open
secret in rather on because the young
people themselves some of them got so
desperate and their families got so
desperate they tried to tell the police
they tried to tell the authorities they
tried to tell the home office and at
every stage it was suppressed so I'm not
surprised that this new report says not
fit for purpose a failure by central
government as well as by the council
well Thunder government perhaps should
have looked read more closely what was
going on in rocdur on but Robin itself
was in denial we had the shocking report
from Alexis Jay at last summer about
1400 children systematically abused over
but all of these years it was a
comprehensive and damning report but
what we've learned today is there are
counselors still in denial seventy
percent of counselling interviewed
disputed the facts of Alexis Jays report
so they can't come to terms with a clear
reality of these systemic abuse that
went on for many many years on their
watch in that city it is not fit for
purpose political correctness running
riot things being stuffed under the
carpet and if police and counselors and
cells were actually part of this abuse
not just turning a blind eye or covering
that the pets explains why it went on
for so long let's going to say it's a
you know this is what about by survivors
and their perseverance and it's easy to
forget about that with all the
finger-pointing that's going on when it
comes to safeguarding they're still not
getting support especially whether or
not it's trying is trying to break
through I mean I think Alexis Jay did
the most amazing report but I recognize
she was let loose on several other
councils she'd do the same because I
think its systemic I don't you know this
crime child abuse is as common as
talking about cornflakes for breakfast
and I don't know why we deny it we talk
about children being safeguarded
crossing roads don't smoke don't drink
don't do this
this is the crime that causes the real
damage and i can tell you you know my
inbox is full every day from councils
that do not listen that are in denial
the council that i live in right now i
read an article the other day that we
don't have a CSE problem where we live
well I'd like to take them to do major
towns and show them exactly I mean is
this a problem that we're only now
coming to terms with the extent of
Charles exit when it's very interesting
I was recently at a child line base
listening to one of our volunteer
counselors talking about the call she
made to childline around 1988 she was 13
she said she was an absolute shocker
she'd ring childline and called them
every rude name in the world because she
wanted to see if they'd be shocked and
when they weren't she got the courage to
tell them what was happening now she at
13 years old she was constantly being
picked up in the town center drunk out
of her head taken home by the police she
was on the edge of crime but what no one
asked was why and the reason was that
she was being sexually exploited she
been groomed she'd been bribed with
cigarettes and alcohol and she was
literally out of her head but because
child I listened and I think this is the
major morale of this tragic story if we
only listen to our young people she got
the courage to move out of the city
however having moved out of the city she
then made a statement to the police she
named the police officer a woman to us
she made a full statement at the end of
it the police officer said now you're
going to make another statement
retracting everything you've said
because if you don't we're going to do
you for wasting police time there is so
much denial going on that we actually do
not still do not want to hear the
message young people are trying to test
families are trying to tell us that they
need support and help but I mean to say
is his cousin's talking about conflict
I'm afraid is it is extraordinary but
it's true you say to people oh I was on
BBC the other day about the people of
roping their license up in West Midlands
oh the 800
different broken licenses well fine but
you know ninety percent of abuse goes
unreported 90 person I two percent of
abuse goes unreported manly a slick and
the counts as I remember meeting Tim a
couple of years ago with the training we
do I am an avid supporter of prevention
if I had known what I would say this
because I teach it and I was a deputy
head I have put together this package of
training which is proven in Kent to work
that training is now flagging up
children who are on the streets I work a
lot with looked after children I you
know troubled families you name it why
are they doing it the number of adults
that have said to me no one in school
ever asked me why I was self harming why
I was running away why I was so angry
and that is awful but I can assure you I
took Tim's advice I wrote to every
single safeguarding board in this
country and only Kent replied and now
Kent have us working across their
council you cannot breakthrough because
the people in the ivory towers who are
the decision makers like status quo kept
as it is now I've been told by my own
counsel we love your training we can't
run it though because we'd flag up too
many referrals today do you think that
the reconstituted of beginning to be
reconstituted historic child sex abuse
inquiry has now got it right I hope so
because this was the last chance saloon
for this entire and I was one of those
who called early on that we needed an
overarching choir to put all these
different forms of historic child abuse
from the church from schools from
children's homes from the BBC from the
National Health Service into some sort
of context so we can see what actually
went on more importantly has there been
a cover-up have there been some sort of
conspiracy that meant that these weren't
properly investigated they are at best
shuffled under the carpet or at worst
actually deliberately and covered up and
as it got closer to Westminster and is
there are political conspiracies were
absolutely essential that we get on with
this thing inquire I think Trevor may
has really done a good job here she has
listened she's had a lot of flak a lot
of changes to this inquiry we've now got
a judge led inquiry I'm sitting on the
Home Affairs Select Committee we will
have the confirmation hearing with the
proposed
chair of the choir an extra next week a
panel transparently nominated and put
forward there are some really good
people on the panel already but people
said well how did they get there what
are their qualifications and it's going
to be on a statutory basis as well this
is going to take a long time it's going
to go everywhere it's got to go
everywhere but with some goodwill behind
it I think people now say this is the
thing to do they go right now hope so I
hope so I think it became clear that
they had to pick someone who was from
another country but understood you know
I jurisdiction I think that became clear
because because we're a small population
and in fact almost everyone has links
with everyone else I don't think either
i think i agree with you she's done a
good job in doing this and starting the
whole thing again because otherwise i
think it would have no credibility this
is her third chance to get it right and
i think you know reading what this judge
has said then I think she is determined
to leave no stone unturned but the
bigger issue still is although yes all
this has got to be exploded it's got to
be cracked open I agree where are we
going to be 10 years time from now what
is actually happening in this country to
prevent the abuse what is it young mums
do i breastfeed do I bottle fee what do
I do with my child how do I know I've
chosen correctly the child not get
paranoid though I'm not there are not
sure I'm not to join you are end of this
let's let us as a society not get
paranoid because I don't like the other
problem let me just let me just make the
point the other problem is that we are
frightening I know it's not frightening
who otherwise would like no it'll hold
axes new hair for a child that is not
not from moment suggesting you are no
don't take it too personal but could you
just listen I'm taking it on my own
shoulders I think that when we set up
child line in 1986 we frightened an
awful lot of United them and
unfortunately we then create a climate
in which every man is a potential abuse
earth rubbish and that is not the case
that is rubbish it is rubbish it is not
the case there are loving caring parents
but they've got to be alert to dangers
that exist in the real world in counsels
up and down the country in television
organizations like the bebes we
everyone has to be a logical person how
long is it's the it's the feeling in
your gut I've been there okay you all
very much indeed